few courses teach the art of problem
formulations but this course is
different we will show how a good
problem formulation may lead to a
surprisingly elegant and practical
algorithm while a bad problem
formulation of the same real-life
problem would lead you nowhere it is
unclear what is the best way to teach
the art of problem formulations I
learned it from countless attempts to
solve real-life problems and most of
these attempts let me know that I will
just show you some failures on the path
to a perfect problem formulation in hope
that you will learn from your mistakes
you will only fail to learn if you do
not learn from failing the first
real-life problem we will discuss came
from a secret Air Force report prepared
during the Cold War General Ross was
interested in interdiction bonding the
Soviet railway network to disrupt
transportation of man and supplies but
the Soviet railway network was so vast
that it was only feasible to bump a few
segments General Ross needed an advice
on which specific segments to bomb he
had neither problem formulation no an
algorithm for the interdiction problem
yet Jesus combined forces with his a
mathematician Ted Harris who realized
that instead of searching for
interdiction minimizing the number of
segments to bomb it makes sense to solve
a completely different problem find a
maximum steady-state flow in the rail
network from a station a to station B
but what is a steady-state flow in
mathematical terms the truth is that
this secret report co-written by a
general and the mathematician still did
not have a rigorous problem formulation
jaysus shared the report to these young
mathematicians randall fort
rate falters own who just finished the
graded studies in mathematics and for
twist Fulkerson came up with this
brilliant problem formulation that lines
the entire field of floors and network
also flows in networks were originally
motivated by the interdiction problem
they now have applications in genomics
in computer revisions in networking to
indeed intrusion detection and a myriad
of other areas but what is a network
Ford and Fulkerson define a network as a
directed graph with special source
vertex special send kinetics and each
edge assign a capacity what is the flow
flow is defined as a function on edges
of the network sites that flow is less
than capacity for each edge and in flow
into each vertex equals to outflow from
this vertex for all vertices except for
source and set the only thing left is to
define what is inflow and outflow inflow
is simply the total flow over all
incoming edges into a vertex V and
outflow is a total flow over all
outgoing edges from there Tex V in this
slide capacities are shown in black and
flows are shown in blue so and the goals
at Ford and Fulkerson set up is to
maximize outflow from the source vertex
in this case the outflow from the source
vertex is 10 plus 6 plus 10 equal to 26
please note that general Ross was
interested in each injection why Ford
and Fulkerson decided to maximize the
flow instead of minimizing the number of
railway segments to bomb because it
turns out that interdiction problem
maximum flow problem are intimately
connected so moment maximum flow is
equivalent to finding the minimum cart
which is shown by dashed edges at this
slide and four targets on theorem states
at maximum flow equals to minimum cut
open any text book on algorithm you will
find an abstract maximum flow problem
typically appearing from nowhere as a
result students have no clue about the
heart work Ford and Fulkerson have to do
to transform the vague army report into
the precise maximum flow problem we want
to change it and teach you how to
transform real-life challenges into
algorithmic problems for example if I
ask you to solve the image segmentation
problem informally we will understand
what problem we want to solve but can
you turn this real-life problem into a
precise problem formulation what is the
input and the output and do you see any
similarity between this problem and the
network flow problem likewise it is
absolutely unclear how to transform the
real-life speech recognition problem
into an algorithmic problem formulation
half a century ago Andrew Viterbi came
up with this brilliant problem
formulation based on hidden Markov
models that is now that are now at the
heart of speech recognition and many
other machine learning applications but
what is the hidden Markov model in this
course we will cover the hidden Markov
models and many other algorithmic ideas
arising from real-life problems our
examples will be mainly taken from
genomics and will be based on the
textbook by informatics algorithm active
learning approach that is now in its
third edition
this textbook covers many algorithm
algorithmic textbook it has a different
philosophy we start every chapter from a
real-life problem and try to teach you
how to transform it into a rigorous
problem formulation for example you will
see how a completely different problem
design of HIV vaccines lead to the same
hidden Markov model framework as the
speech recognition problem we will thus
implement the Viterbi algorithm and
we'll apply it for analyzing genome this
will illustrate that vastly different
real-life problems may lead to identical
problem formulations